pour vous remercier d'avoir participé à
notre prompteur challenge avec gilles on
va vous montrer comment tout ça
fonctionne mais là il était à 5 6 mètres
de moi la voyez de procter c'est en fait
une glace sans tain c'est un vieux truc
de magicien il ya le texte que j'ai
écrit tout à l'heure il est question de
garance parti dont je ne sais pas
pourquoi donc les textes il est là et il
est également là il ya une petite
molette magique qui est activé par
théodore a baissé à cette manne est
magique et donc quand je les ai bien là
y aller je vois le texte qui défile et
j'écoute attentivement gym et je le suis
[Musique]
un
vieux
tech
[Rires]
ça
[Musique]
fait du bien
on
non
[Musique]
[Rires]
quelques vélos